Chúng ta mấy, a coi mắt quò như thế tuyệt
Chúng ta mấy, bố ra nó
Chúng ta mấy, cho bò hình thường này
Hai chú, Rồi Bốt, có thể hoạt động, dào tý vực mới, khách kì mà tưởng mặt đường mà
Nó có thể nó được mừng tư tình
Tưởng mừng bôi là các cái biểu cả mất trình đường mà
Các nhau
Sường sắc bình mại là một thời xí dụng chất lệ lòng sớt
Nó sẽ cứ đồng phần khó và phần tay
Bữa Thị chào các bạn chào của con đu bóng hoa bất tử được chết ngách trên thằng đu bóng
Nặt đu bóng só là sấu ngày mà bân phía công ty vật kìm kế phần tướng
Cơ động của 2 con đu bóng
Và bân phóp lịch thì sẽ là khi người đu cộng nghe ai vào trong cái con đu bóng đồng thời
Cóng một cái tinh năng rất đặc biệt
Cé phy hình ảnh của các thằng hoa sẽ đu hình thị ngay trên
Đấy tiêm lết của đu bóng thị ngách thị mà đu ra ngon tài kế đu hòa
Cô đu bóng hình ảnh xảnh và môi trường và khó lượng người quá lại
Vông thời thích ở ngoài mùa chời
Nó sẽ đu hòa khách sau với những tính toán mà nào
Chúng tôi phải trải đu vân phía thầy nghe
Tân chẫn chào nó phù hợp với lại kế thật tế
Tại vì không dàng của đu hòa